seven years ago for one night the
attention of the national political
class in this country was on a small
town in the middle of Virginia called
Farmville the occasion at that time was
the vice presidential debate between Tim
Kaine and Mike Pence a handful of our
farm farmville's 8 000 residents were in
attendance for this event and most of
the debate focused on issues that no one
even pretends to care about anymore like
Donald Trump's tax returns and the fact
that Trump called Rosie O'Donnell a fat
slob there's a lot of talk about the
internal politics of Faraway countries
like Syria
what didn't come up in any meaningful
way is what either party would do to
help towns like Farmville and that's
kind of odd when you think about it by
the time Tim Kaine Mike Pence and the
national press Corps showed up in 2016
Farmville had been bleeding population
for many years the median income in
Farmville was an obvious cause for
concern it was less than half the median
income in the United States and dropping
thousands of residents lived in poverty
and yet despite all that
um you know all of the residents of
Farmville heard during the debate were
vague promises and cliches about an
economy that would soon work for
everyone leave no one behind
seven years later both major political
parties have had a chance to run the
white house uh the decline of Farmville
Virginia has only continued in the
meantime four years after that vice
presidential debate the one with all the
promises where all the promises were
made Farmville ranked as the single
poorest town in all of Virginia with
nearly a third of residents living below
the poverty line in 2021 the median
household income in Farmville was under
thirty six thousand dollars that's the
median
compared to more than seventy thousand
dollars in the United States generally
now what's happening in Farmville isn't
unique multiply the story of Farmville
Virginia by the thousands of small towns
all over the country that have
deteriorated in recent years and you get
some sense of the scale of American
decline that's been completely ignored
in Washington
now politicians they like to use these
towns as props or as picturesque
backdrops for their televised debates
but once the cameras leave
so do the politicians
so does the media so does everyone
now one of the Farmville residents they
left behind is named Oliver Anthony he's
a former factory worker who lives with
his three dogs in the town and last week
I briefly talked about Anthony's
Breakout song rich men north of Richmond
the song isn't just about the failings
of this country's political leaders who
long ago abandoned people like Oliver
Anthony it's also about dignity about
personal responsibility about
spirituality all verboden Topics in the
music industry you've probably seen the
song on social media it's everywhere now
you can't escape it um we played it on
the show on Friday now for context
Anthony was completely unknown and
recording songs with his iPhone for an
audience of a few dozen on YouTube as
recently as last week at this time seven
days ago nobody had ever heard of him
here he was on August 7th watch
so hey
it's August the 7th 2023.
and as of this recording tomorrow on
Tuesday radio WV is going to upload the
debut of Richmond north of Richmond
and it's going to be the first song to
get out there that's been recorded on
the real microphone in the real camera
and not just on my cell phone and Lord
willin it's going to get some traffic
it's gonna get some traffic it certainly
got some traffic that's for sure
a few days later that guy had three of
the top 10 songs on iTunes three of them
he was performing for a crowd of
thousands in North Carolina where they
were all singing along as if they'd been
singing his songs for years so here he
is performing Richmond North Richmond
Richmond for the for the massive crowd
in North Carolina watch
[Music]
I've been selling my soul working all
day double time hours for both paid so I
can sit out here waste my life away
drive back home and drown the troubles
away it's a damn shame what the world's
got into for people like me and block
you is I could just wake up and it not
be true but it is Lord it is living in
the New World
with an old song
the rich man nor for Richmond Lord knows
they all just wanna have total control I
know what you think I don't know what
you do and they don't think you know but
I know that you do cause your dollar
hates and it's time to know him cause a
rich man no the reds man
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish politicians look out for minors
and not those miners on an island
somewhere Lord we got kids in the
streets ain't got nothing to eat and he
hold me milk and Welfare my God history
five foot three and you're 300 pounds
taxes I'm not
men are putting them sounds six feet in
the ground there's all this damn country
does is keep on kicking them down
Oliver Anthony and the many people
cheering him on uh they're not supposed
to exist or at least you're not supposed
to know that they do
you're not supposed to hear from any of
them
they don't belong to any of the
perpetually oppressed classes you're
told endlessly to grieve for they don't
go around identifying AS
lgbtq2s Plus or whatever these are
people who have actual useful skills
people who want to work for a living
these are people who don't think their
sexuality or race is a substitute for
personality or ethics these are
religious people men and women who
despise sexual degenerates who
appreciate good music
who understand that they themselves are
not all-powerful and all-knowing
they are not the controlled opposition
the left has grown familiar with these
are in a word normal people it's as
simple as that Innovation refunds has
been helping small businesses that
qualify to get a business payroll tax
refund through the employee retention
credit or also known as the ERC the ERC
is a tax refund for businesses that kept
employees on payroll for parts of 2020
and 2021. if you own a business with
more than five employees you could have
money waiting to be claimed are you
uncertain about your eligibility for the
ERC Innovation refunds is a team of
independent tax attorneys that will
collaborate collaborate with your CPA to
assess your eligibility ensuring you
feel confident before submitting your
application they've already helped
thousands of eligible businesses apply
for the ERC Innovation refunds does not
provide tax or legal advice they work
with an independent network of tax
professionals and will share information
with them to evaluate and process your
claims go to getrefunds.com to determine
eligibility if you qualify you could be
on your way to receiving money for your
business there's no upfront charge since
they don't get paid unless you get paid
go to getrefunds.com or dial 1-843
refunds that's getrefunds.com or 1843
refunds terms and conditions apply with
everything going on in the world right
now you could really use a good night's
sleep that's why you need to check out
Helix Matrix Helix has harnessed years
of extensive match expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience they just launched their new
Helix Elite the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for years now and I
absolutely love it night after night I
sleep like a sweet sweet baby and I want
the same for you Helix has a sleep quiz
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
because why would you buy a mattress
made for somebody else go to
helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away for a limited time Helix
is giving you 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
take advantage of this amazing offer at
helixsleep.com Walsh with Helix better
sleep starts now
now Anthony made much of this very clear
this weekend moments before the
performance that you just saw he
delivered an important message to the
crowd that had gathered and as you watch
this
I want you to put yourself in Anthony's
position for a moment just a few days
ago you're a complete unknown no one
listens to your music no one's heard of
you now all of a sudden you're getting
all kinds of offers for interviews and
record deals and everything you're one
of the top trending topics across all
social media platforms
well given that sort of platform and
that attention how would you begin your
first show after all this attention
here's how Oliver Anthony did it watch
Psalm 37 12-20
the wicked plot against the righteous
and gnashed their teeth at them but the
Lord laughs at the wicked for he knows
their day is coming
the wicked draw the sword and bend the
bow to bring down the poor and needy to
slay those whose ways are upright
but their swords will pierce their own
hearts and their bows will be broken
better the little that have
righteousness
than the wealth of many Wicked
for the power of the wicked will be
broken but the Lord upholds the
righteous
the blameless spend their days under the
Lord's care and their inheritance will
endure forever
in times of disaster they will not
wither
a days of famine they will have plenty
but the Wicked Will perish
though the Lord's enemies are like the
flowers of the field
they will be consumed and they will go
up and smoke
so he opens his concert now with a plug
for his Instagram or with some kind of
narcissistic celebration of his own
success instead he quotes Psalm 37 the
Wicked Will perish he says and the crowd
erupts
which is quite an Applause line
they've probably never seen anything
like that at least not from a famous
musician this isn't a Sam Smith Satanism
or cardi B's sexual perversion in fact
most of the people in that crowd
probably haven't even heard a message
like that in their churches where most
pastors would consider it insufficiently
welcoming to quote the Bible's warnings
about the punishments doled out to
evildoers
so it's not just that he started his
first concert really you know after
getting all this tension now you didn't
just start it with a Bible verse he
chose that Bible verse
now I don't think that Anthony was
trying to do anything revolutionary by
reading that particular passage it just
means something to him you can tell he's
getting emotional reading it it
resonates with him so he read it
and it's a beautiful verse and an
important one he's a normal authentic
guy which is the whole appeal
he's also a great musician
now that simple fact makes him a clear
and present danger to the many
talentless and eternally bitter members
of the so-called entertainment industry
along with their friends in the equally
joyless news media and that's why
predictably Rolling Stone just published
the first hit piece on Oliver Anthony
many more will surely follow but for its
part Rolling Stone shocked Anthony's
success up to quote right-wing
influencers who have artificially
promoted Anthony's Song they say
now the piece mentions me a few other
people who are guilty of of promoting
Oliver Anthony for the record I very
much object to being called an
influencer
but we have to ask is that really the
explanation for the success of Richmond
north of Richmond
my love to take credit for it if I could
but is that really how it works you saw
the clips we just showed you
the crowd didn't look like a bunch of
influencers to me and they didn't even
look like the sorts of people who pay
very close attention to influencers how
many of those people are even on Twitter
they seem again like just normal people
TMZ managed to miss the point even more
implying that Anthony wrote the song in
order to make money that's why he wrote
it here's what they wrote quote this is
a pretty fascinating Trend we're seeing
it appears when right-wingers perceive
something like a song they think
addresses their Grievances and
perspectives they lean into it and from
that small sample size we've noticed it
can be effective in the marketplace
capitalism baby it Reigns Supreme
in other words he's just trying to make
a quick Buck capitalism baby they sneer
as if it was as if it was so obvious
that a song like this would instantly go
to number one on iTunes
as if Anthony stood in the woods next to
his deer stand and played an acoustic
song about his troubles as a working man
all in some cynical ploy to make
millions of dollars from an audience who
at that point didn't even know he
existed
no it's pretty obvious that what
happened is this Anthony was singing
from his heart about his own experiences
he assumed the song would be heard by
the same few dozen people who heard his
other songs
and he was fortunately quite wrong in
that assumption
I was weak as these hit pieces are the
truth is we know that Rolling Stone and
TMZ are just firing the warning shots
here
we already know that the media will set
to work to destroy Oliver Anthony no
doubt they're digging through his past
right now looking for skeletons as we
speak
and maybe they'll find some
everyone has a few
honestly who cares
as The Daily Beast at Huffington Post
ghouls scour through Anthony's social
media feeds start interviewing his high
school friends looking for dirt
let's take a step back here because what
we're seeing here as remarkable as it is
shouldn't be viewed in isolation
consider this all of the biggest hit
songs that have gotten the buzz and
attention in recent weeks have been
country songs
recently the top three songs on
Billboard were country songs never
happened before
before Anthony it was Jason Aldean with
a song centered around similar themes
try that in a small town Aldine sang
and that touched off what like a
two-week news cycle
the media freaked out about the Aldine
song just as they're starting to freak
out about Anthony's Song because it's
music that attacks the elites and gives
voice to the normal concerns of normal
people
Americans who aren't demented as it
turns out don't like it when hordes of
BLM Riders torch small businesses and
courthouses in their communities
they don't like it when politicians send
billions of dollars to Ukraine while
towns like Farmville Fall Apart
normal people have been told to shut up
about all this for years and years
but now those people have a voice you
know
a moment ago I scoffed at the idea that
Anthony would make a song like this as
some sort of marketing or
self-promotional strategy and that is an
idea that deserves to be scoffed at
because it's totally absurd given the
context
but we should note that yes there is
indeed a huge market for this kind of
thing just like there's a huge market
for movies like sound of freedom
that's the other thing that's that's the
other context we should consider all
this in
think about the songs that are getting
all the attention right now the biggest
hit songs right now and the biggest hit
movies
millions and millions of people normal
people are starving for art that speaks
to them and their values and concerns
there is in fact many millions of
dollars to be made here that wasn't
Anthony's motivation but the money is
there to be made
and now he'll likely make some of it
whether he wanted to or not
this just makes it all the more
remarkable that the mainstream music
industry just like the mainstream film
industry
absolutely refuses to cater to this
audience or give them art that will
actually resonate with them
now sure you can make plenty of money by
churning out another demented rap song
you know that talks about female
genitalia and graphic terms and openly
encourages listeners to act in depraved
and Lawless and self-destructive ways
you can make plenty of money with
another mindless soulless pop song that
might as well been generated by AI but
the songs that have set the world on
fire recently the ones that have topped
the charts and gotten people talking
dominated the news cycle for weeks
are songs that connect with an audience
that despises all of that stuff
Anthony sings in Richmond north of
Richmond that he's uh that he's an old
soul living in a new world and those of
us who relate to that lyric as I
certainly do
are are made to feel this way in large
part because of the sort of art quote
unquote that the entertainment industry
vomits out
we see all that stuff and we listen to
it and our souls are crushed just a
little more each time it Grieves us to
be surrounded by such ugliness and
stupidity
and to think that so many people are
just marinating in this filth without
realizing what it's doing to them
there are many of us who feel that way
so many that we made a literal overnight
Superstar out of one simple authentic
guy strumming his guitar in the woods
so the question is given that this huge
Market exists and that it is hungry for
this kind of content this kind of art
why won't the entertainment industry
serve it
even if it is just for the sake of
capitalism baby as TMZ says why don't
they produce songs like rich men north
of Richmond
well the answer is exactly what we've
already established they hate normal
people you know people who read their
Bibles and have traditional quote
unquote values and care about things
like hard work and honesty they hate us
and they want us all to become lazy
helpless degenerate parasites
they want to create a population of
stupid weird Hollow people
they will even forego profit to make
that happen that's How Deeply they hate
normalcy
that's how badly they want to destroy it
which fine
if they don't want our money no problem
we'll give it to guys like Oliver
Anthony instead hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there